Aladdin killed Jasmine in his efforts to
impress the princess and winner hand in
marriage this lovable Street rat made
one fatal error this is it safe no
Jasmine no it is not safe Magic Carpet
Ride more like tragic Carpet Ride did
you see what I did there pretty proud of
that one
[Music]
internet welcome to film Theory you
ain't never had a channel like me unless
of course you watch Game Theory too in
which case yeah it's they're largely the
same cover different IP I suppose or not
actually whoopsie so anyway Disney's not
doing that hot these days huh they've
had flop after flop the box office tent
pull Brands like Marvel and Star Wars
are struggling their back catalog's been
tarnished by an onslaught of low effort
live action remakes and even the parks
division is sweating heavily due to
lower attendance and the shutdown of a
350 Million Dollar Hotel merely a year
after its opening really kind of makes
you yearn for the Golden Days of classic
Disney right the Renaissance Era where
every movie was a certified classic that
would go on to shape the childhoods for
generations of kids I'm talking about
the ogs here Lion King Little Mermaid
Beauty and the Beast Aladdin all the
ones that have been bled dry for an
extra billion dollars at the box office
their originals are revered for a reason
beautiful animation amazing songs
Timeless stories traumatic nightmare
fuel that'll need years of therapy to
process oh I'm sorry did you miss that
last one locked it out of your memory
and all that well let me refresh you the
Disney Classics were Rife for Terror
there were the scary moments of course
like Mufasa's death the wolf attacks the
Beauty and the Beast Hercules literally
withering to dust and Prince Eric's ship
burning with him and his dog's lives on
the line then of course he had the
disturbing themes that could also scar
you Belle having to teach an angry
violent man how to love Belle falling
for the Beast because of Stockholm
syndrome Belle being ostracized by
Society for being a smart woman honestly
there's a lot in Beauty and the Beast
but that movie is far from alone Claude
frollo's addiction to pain Ariel given
up her voice for a man that she met once
Aladdin using an enslaved creature to
help him lie about his life so he can
trick a woman he's met once into
marrying him all right you bad boy but
not only is the land responsible for
shamelessly gaslighting Jasmine
throughout the majority of the movie
He's also responsible for her murder but
she doesn't die in the movie I hear you
saying and yeah well you're technically
correct his actions would have
definitely killed her see about halfway
through the film Aladdin takes Jasmine
on a Magic Carpet Ride during what's
probably the film's most iconic musical
number A Whole New World and during this
little romantic getaway the pair fly out
of agriba to go visit the pyramids of
Egypt the Acropolis of Athens Greece and
the Forbidden City of Beijing China
honestly it's a pretty great date on
paper but when you actually stop and
think about what's going on on here you
realize one huge problem they do all of
this in the span of a single night I
mean is that possible and if it is they
must be traveling at speeds that would
rip human flesh off the bone really puts
this joke into a brand new context thank
you for choosing veggie carpet for all
your travel needs thank you goodbye now
goodbye goodbye goodbye indeed Genie so
we ran the numbers to see if Aladdin's
Magic Carpet Ride would be a one-way
trip to romance or A Whole New World of
Pain join me friends as I make it
crystal clear that now they're in a
whole screwed world with you don't you
dare close your eyes so for us to figure
out exactly how badly Aladdin and
Jasmine would have been injured during
their little romantic jaunt across the
historical World figure we should
probably narrow down the main ways that
we see this killing them the big two how
high they're flying and how fast they're
flying let's start off with how high
they actually flew we see Aladdin and
Jasmine flying through clouds at
multiple points in the song which set
off some alarm bells in my brain since
you know humans aren't technically
supposed to be up that high see the
higher up you go the less dead against
the air is and the lower the level of
oxygen when you get high enough there
literally isn't enough oxygen in the air
for you to survive and that's without
even mentioning how cold it's going to
be the further up you go so overall not
exactly looking that great for our two
little lovebirds that said with going up
this High straight up kill him to find
out I first decided to figure out how
high they actually got and I did that by
identifying the clouds that they're
flying through given the shape and
volume of the clouds I figured that they
had to be either cumulus or cumulonimbus
given how fluffy and full they looked
now cumulus clouds are found up to 6 500
feet in the sky while cumulonimbus
clouds can reach as high as 20 000 feet
much higher so which altitude are we
talking about here well given that we
also see the carpet fly through a flock
of what appear to be cranes during part
of the song we can actually identify
these clouds as cumulus since cranes
typically fly at an altitude of roughly
six thousand to seven thousand feet as
such we're just gonna call this altitude
right here about 6 500 feet or 2 000
meters to keep things simple so how cold
would it be up there and would Aladdin
and Jasmine have died from some
sub-freezing temperatures well yeah at
about 6 6 500 feet the temperature is
going to be about 35 degrees Fahrenheit
or just about one to two degrees Celsius
slightly above freezing so it might be a
bit nippy for this couple especially
Jasmine considering how she's dressed
and given that they're spending the
entire night up there and likely
experiencing some intense wind chill
from flying fast they might be hot under
the collar but the rest of their bodies
are going to be ice cold and sick
they're gonna be sick as well altitude
sickness to be exact between five
thousand and ten thousand feet in the
air the air pressure is low enough to
cause headaches nausea fatigue dizziness
and shortness of breath this happens
because of a fallen barometric pressure
which causes the tissue in your lungs
and brain to swell in an attempt to get
more oxygen that being said at this
altitude while it would be unpleasant it
wouldn't outright kill them fun fact by
the way all of this is actually why
planes are pressurized it keeps the
pressure the same as where he took off
so the oxygen levels remain stable while
also protecting you from the colder
temperatures at the much higher cruising
altitudes okay so if the Height's gonna
make them chilly and woozy what about
how fast they're flying well to figure
this one out we're gonna need a few key
bits of information how far they
traveled in the time frame they do it in
let's start off with the distance shall
we obviously the pairs start off in the
city of Agrabah but Agrabah it's not
exactly a real place so how are we
supposed to figure out where we're gonna
be well we've got ourselves a few
options geographically we know that it's
a city in the middle of a desert but we
also know it's close to either a lake or
large river we know this thanks to a
moment in the middle of the movie when
Aladdin is nearly drowned by jafar's
goons additionally we have to remember
that the opening song is straight up
called Arabian Nights implying that
Agrabah is in Arabia a very specific
place this peninsula in West Asia
between Africa and Southeast Asia so
where exactly are we well a lot of fans
online assume that Agrabah is located
near the river Jordan because in the
intro the merchant says this welcome to
Agrabah city of Mystery
however when you actually break down
what he's saying here he's not denoting
how close to the River Jordan they are
only that Agrabah has the finest Goods
on this side of the river Jordan that
could literally mean anywhere to the
east or the west of the river you know
basically the entire planet Plus in the
Aladdin animated series though we do
occasionally see a river in the show
it's never explicitly called anything
let alone the Jordan so long story short
we're actually gonna need something else
here elsewhere in the opening song The
Merchant says that he comes from a far
away place where the Caravan camels roam
camel Caravans are actually very much a
real thing most commonly found in the
Saharan Desert of Northern Africa though
certain breeds of camels were also used
for this sort of travel and trade in the
Middle East Central Asia Mongolia and
China again not really helping us narrow
things down all that much so what else
could we look at we could look at where
the actual story of Aladdin originated
which isn't where you'd expect the
original version of the tale actually
comes from China again not really
working for our story here because this
one's clearly based on the Middle East
so then I thought maybe we could use the
clothing of the characters and
architecture of the city to try and pin
something down the architecture from
agribuzz Palace clearly took inspiration
from the Taj Mahal of India it's even
located in a city named Agra so I
thought we might be getting somewhere
but here's the thing India it's nowhere
near the Arabian Peninsula Arabian
Knights are not happening there in that
subcontinent so back to the drawing
board the clothing the clothing worn by
characters like Aladdin Jasmine and the
sultan resemble what would have been
worn by citizens of the Iraqi City
Baghdad though with a lot of artistic
and cultural shortcuts and inaccuracies
thrown in by Disney so that right there
it's a pretty strong lead that gets even
stronger once you consider this
according to John musker co-director of
the film The First treatment of the
movie was set in Baghdad Iraq however
while the movie was in development the
first Gulf War broke out the area and
corporate executive Roy Disney insisted
that Aladdin couldn't be explicitly set
in Baghdad and thus agrabo was created
as a stand-in and there is a bit of
evidence in the movie for why this lines
up with everything else that we've
talked about geographically Baghdad
lines up with what we see around Agrabah
with the vast swaths of desert the city
is is built on the Tigris river which
could be a stand-in for all the bodies
of water that we see in the movie in the
show Baghdad was historically one of the
most important Urban stops along the
Silk Road which would have seen camel
Caravan stopping by frequently it's also
right on the edge of Arabia so could be
argued to be a part of it thus giving it
Arabian Nights additionally in the Cave
of Wonders you can spot this statue of
lamasu an ancient Mesopotamian deity
which originated in Sumerian territory
very close to where modern day Baghdad
is located pretty much all the clues
match which means that we're going to be
using Baghdad as our stand-in for
Agrabah for our purposes today so now
that we know roughly where Aladdin and
Jasmine start their Journey where do
they actually go well over the course of
the song we see them fly through the
pyramids and pass the Sphinx outside
Cairo Egypt then up to the Acropolis and
Athens Greece before completing their
little song at the Forbidden City in
Beijing China doesn't take a geographic
genius to see that that right there that
is a long journey but just how long
exactly is it well let's break it down
assuming that the carpet took the
shortest possible route between each
stop on its Journey it's roughly 780
miles or 1 1260 kilometers from Baghdad
to Cairo the second leg from Cairo to
Athens is a bit shorter 700 miles or
1120 kilometers the most harrowing leg
of the journey would be from Athens to
Beijing so they can catch those
fireworks which is a staggering
4730 miles or 7 600 kilometers oh I just
feel my legs cramping up thinking about
that flight finally flying from Beijing
back to Baghdad to get home in time for
the sultan to not start a man hunt it
would be another painful 4 000 miles
3920 miles to be specific or 6 310
kilometers just in case you weren't
keeping track there that means that
during their little date night Aladdin
and Jasmine flew a jaw-dropping 10 000
130 miles or 16 300 kilometers that is a
lot if you did this on a normal
commercial flight it would take you over
20 hours the longest normally operated
non-stop flight in the world flies
between Singapore and New York City that
one clocks in at just over 9500 miles or
15 300 kilometers and takes nearly 19
agonizing hours so now that we know how
far they flew how fast were they going
there since Aladdin gets Jasmine back to
Agrabah before any sorts of alarms of
missing princess arrays this absolutely
would not have taken the 20 plus hours
that it would take a modern airplane in
fact when I started researching this
Theory I actually wondered if it was
going to be possible for all of these
locations to be night time at the same
time but considering that Beijing is the
only real outlier here just five hours
ahead of Baghdad Cairo and Athens it
should be possible but that does beg a
bit of a bigger question here sure it's
possible for all these places to be
night at the same time but how long do
Aladdin and Jasmine actually have to fly
this far when Aladdin gets to Jasmine's
window it's already dark out with the
Stars clearly visible in the night sky
which puts it decidedly after Sunset and
they still need to catch the fireworks
over in Beijing before heading back to
Agrabah so when are those fireworks
possibly Happening Now sadly I have to
admit I do not have a thousand-year-old
fireworks schedule from Beijing to
double check the time here but you know
what we're gonna make a pretty
reasonable estimate first off we're
gonna assume that this is happening on
the Chinese New Year for a couple of
reasons during the scene we see a
dancing Dragon which is a traditional
Chinese puppet used during celebrations
the large impressive display of
fireworks also tells us that this is
some sort of a festival and this is
important because fireworks during the
Chinese New Year can last into the wee
hours of the morning giving Aladdin and
Jasmine the most possible time to leave
Baghdad Agrabah pass by the pyramids in
Acropolis and then head on over to
Beijing to watch the fireworks on this
building now right there that's the
Forbidden City an Imperial Palace at the
center of the city of Beijing of all the
landmarks that they visit this one was
actually the last to be constructed
completed in the year 1420. so using
that we know that at the earliest this
movie can take place is the year 1420
and just to keep things simple we're
going to be using that as our new year
here the Chinese New Year is a festival
that celebrates the beginning of a new
year on the traditional Chinese calendar
which usually falls on the second new
moon after the winter solstice in the
year 1420 the Chinese New Year began on
January 24th and according to the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the sun set in Baghdad
that day at approximately 5 22 PM let's
just make it an even 5 30 to keep it
nice in modern day China during
festivals like the Chinese New Year
festivals can be set off continuously
for up to two hours after midnight so
that right there gives us our flight cut
off we are getting to Beijing by 2 A.M
at the latest using what we found out
earlier about flight distances if you
were to board a commercial flight from
Baghdad to I wrote to Athens to Beijing
that would normally take over 12 hours
to fly and that's not even considering
the fact that they need to be back in
agraba by the morning but since Beijing
is five hours ahead of Baghdad that puts
the time there at 10 30. meaning that
Aladdin and Jasmine only have roughly
three and a half hours to travel the 6
000 plus miles between all their stops
before that fireworks display ends in
Beijing so to make it they need to be
traveling just about 1
775 miles an hour or nearly 3 000
kilometers an hour that is more than
twice the speed of sound which opens up
a massive can of worms because moving
faster than Mach 2 that is no joke
they're going to be subjected to some
crazy forces using this drag equation
and the fact that Disney mandates their
lands and theme parks to be between a
height of 5 foot 10 and 6 foot we can
calculate that Aladdin and Jasmine are
both facing roughly 144
000 Newtons of force every single second
that they're flying on that carpet to
put that insane amount of force into
perspective and average person
experiences about 67 000 Newtons of
force in a 40 mile per hour car
collision and that's just one quick hit
not every single second that they're in
the air the strongest bone in the human
body is the femur your thigh bone and
snap in a femur only takes about 4 000
Newtons of direct pressure during the
state Aladdin forced him and Jasmine to
experience more than 36 times that
amount of force I actually wondered if
this would be powerful enough to rip the
skin clean off their bones but running
those numbers against the tensile
strength of skin meant that you needed
something closer to 10 million Newtons
to make it happen it would still be
enough to break their bodies and send
Aladdin and Jasmine hurdling off the
carpet falling to the ground below in
case of emergency the exits are here
here here here anywhere yeah you could
say that again and if they're lucky the
pain from snapping all their bones would
cause them to pass out before they hit
the ground and died it's pretty dark
definitely not what Disney wants us to
imagine happening to their beloved
characters but here's the thing this
isn't the only incarnation of these
characters to exist within the massive
Canon of the Disney Cinematic Universe
in fact there's another official version
of this tragic Carpet Ride in the live
action remake if you don't remember this
thing I mean fair but the long and short
of it is that this new version doesn't
quite put the world into a whole new
world they don't fly across continents
they don't visit the pyramids or the
Acropolis or the Forbidden City instead
everything from this musical number in
the new movie are things that you could
feasibly find in and around the
immediate area of Baghdad during this
time period you have palm trees
elephants mountains rivers deserts this
version of Aladdin and Jasmine aren't
flying thousands of miles given the
princess a new lease on life and Spark
in a globetrotting romance it all just
feels very small very real not very
magical and there I think is the lesson
that we can take away from all of this
scientifically speaking yes this remake
handles A Whole New World way more
realistically than the animated version
did but in doing so it's really a slap
to the face of what this moment meant to
the story it took all the fun and Whimsy
out of this journey it took away the
magic and instead it turned it into
something boring and even though I'm a
man of science at the end of the day
sometimes you really need that bit of
magic but hey if you want another
Aladdin Theory right now why not check
out our video where we tell Aladdin
exactly how to get Jasmine to marry him
in just a single wish or if you want to
know how horrifying another Disney
Renaissance classic would be if it were
real check out our Theory where we see
what a real-life Little Mermaid would
actually look like spoiler alert you
will not want to kiss the girl and as
always remember my friends it's all just
a theory a film Theory and cuts